guys fer Shur Oh
looking straight your is Li hold the
phone you are fully plugged bro we dad
was about the buon natale
everybody knows that it's an unwritten
rule lawyers cannot collide Wow erect
fine fine take five crank down I'm not
used to sitting up with master bean I'm
just punching myself in the nuts
I like it so far oh my oh there it is
eyes down here fellas oh yeah your legs
feel like puddings swimming in the
swimming pool of life Blake it's cute
it's cute raccoon doesn't mean it
doesn't deserve to die because I'm a man
what is the absolute least amount of
money you could get paid to blow at that
hour talkin if I'm honest with myself
yeah I have to say $900
walked you guys lead me back to the VIP
booth in like five minutos that's
Spanish for minutes chill out it's on
because I told them that you guys were
coke dealers and all three of them have
really bad coke problems you're not the
boss of me you fake-ass grown up I'm
sorry maybe if you weren't so immature I
wouldn't have to hold your hand and wipe
your ass for you okay that was one time
and I told you I've never been camping
before
further down
let us join some short stacks yeah and
six difficult order than you think you
thought you could get away with it yeah
I will your face Adam this is so dumb
alright I'd like to get to this photo
shoot on time try being a pacifist I'll
be a pacifist
I'll pass my fist through your face
today's my birthday what was that that's
the nurse what is it that's not beer no
it's whiskey I watered it down though
okay all right fine with beer here we go
coming around that mountain she'll be
coming around that mountain talking
about mountains y'all Catherine
zeta-jones she dives beneath lasers ooh
she has entrapped me
oh nothing makes me barf it's weird I've
got a stomach of Steel atom scientists
developed that it would make you vomit
because scientists made this yeah who
believes in scientists dude I'm gonna
give this little tester ooh hmm that's
weird definitely don't feel like barfing
right now oh wait no I'm barfing I'm
barfing right now I'm not barfing wait
I'm barfing I'm barfing those scientists
better check your hypotenuse is dude Oh